what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today um i'm going to be talking about
i'm going to be talking about dating
advice that i would give
to women um before i start do not forget
to subscribe to the channel and bring
that notification bell
that way you're gonna be notified of my
daily videos um so i've been doing more
of like
these unedited like driving videos
mostly because
like i've been having issues with stream
labs
so if any of you guys are going to like
tech stuff please slide in my ig dms
because
i've been having issues i sort of got up
and having such issues
okay so what i want to speak to is the
young
women on this app
look a lot of the girls giving dating
advice
telling you to like that it's perfectly
okay to like sleep around
do whatever you want a lot of these
women
really don't have your best intentions
at heart i don't think a lot of times
it's conscious
but i'm just gonna give you guys a
little bit of an example right now
um everyone's been in school at some
point right
and if you were like me when you weren't
a straight a student
at some point you failed the test right
like
um i don't know like i was really bad at
math so i would always do bad at math
tests
and there is nothing worse than being in
a class and feeling like you're the only
one
that failed the test right
so i remember like getting a test back
that i failed
and the most comforting thing that i
could like hear
was somebody say like me too i failed
too because then you don't feel like
you're alone
and you know like you guys have heard me
talk you know me pretty
pretty well i'd say some of you that
have been watching me for a while
i'm not a super malicious person right
i'm not
i'm not like someone that like wishes
prays on the downfall of other people
but
i can't deny that there's a part of me
that feels like
misery loves company when i do bad i
don't want to be
bad by myself i don't want to be alone
um and that's what i see in a lot of
like modern
dating advice today it's a lot of women
that have made bad decisions
and a lot of times you can see that
they've made bad decisions because
half the time the people giving dating
advice are 35
45 and still single so
they give these young impressionable
girls
bad dating advice like you know
it's okay to have one night stance and
there aren't repercussions from it like
it's it's totally
like like uh
you can't do any wrong you know you you
know being
heavy is okay and there aren't bad
repercussions from it
like no that's not true and you know
i'm not like you guys can like look at
me i'm not the thinnest person in the
world and
sometimes it was really hard for me in
college because
you know all my friends were like 20 30
pounds heavier than me i've never been
like the skinny skinny girl
but i'm never gonna tell someone like
get to my weight and like i'm super
happy at my weight because i'm not
um like i'm genuinely not like i'm super
self-conscious
um i'm kind of addicted to sugar and a
lot of times it feels like there's no
way out and i'm gonna have to deal with
this
like sugar addiction the rest of my life
i love working out but like sugar oh my
gosh
it's that um
i hope i'm not getting too off topic but
but this is what girls do with dating
advice they
they say oh you can be as big as you
want and they're
all guys like as long as they're a
quality guy that they'll watch you
that's not that's not true you know it's
perfectly reasonable to say i want to
raise my kids to be healthy because
when you get married and you have kids
it's not about you it's about your kids
and wanting a partner that like is super
healthy i totally get
like that makes sense um
and it's the same thing with like
sleeping around like wanting to teach
your sons and your daughters like
that sleeping around isn't okay and that
you know to have a high standards for
yourself and your body
like that's perfectly reasonable for a
guy to ask
so if you choose to like eat whatever
you want do whatever you want
um the the consequences
you know there there are consequences
for that and
um that's what bothers me is it's
clearest day sometimes
for me to see that a lot of girls give
advice
and encourage their friends to do like
hoe things eat out whatever
because they're miserable or they are
unhappy in their decisions and they
don't want to be alone
and i don't think it's always conscious
to the person like giving the advice
because there's been times where i like
have encouraged
like you know eating out or like
you know going out to the bar or
something when
i just didn't want to make those
decisions by myself and it's clear as
day to me now but
you know i don't think like at the time
i was maliciously just like
thinking that
that like i wanted their downfall or
anything i don't know if that makes
sense like i don't i
genuinely don't think it's conscious but
hindsight's always 20 20.
and that's just like my two cents so let
me know in the comments if you guys
agree or you disagree do not forget to
subscribe to the channel bring the
notification bell
um i love you guys send this to females
because
girls don't like me like they never want
to watch my stuff
so i'll talk to you guys next time